Wow cue the sob chanted earlier relax
still got my acid I'm ready for the acid
life
later Oh
we better get going huh no it's finally
kicking in what do you see
it's a beautiful dancing angel doll but
flames flickering from her fingertips
it's beautiful
no that's a guy on fire damn it I almost
got a bum Tod this sucks - oh boy he's
catching see you next year psycho dude
yeah I'm just glad that I got to stay in
a hotel for once man now I can say that
I can never show my face at this
convention again ders just drive me home
I want to forget any of this ever
happened
you're late
oh no I don't I don't think that's a
good idea not right now this is not
negotiable
right here drive
you